do you keep those sessions if it's like
a 2016 session is it somewhere yeah like
you have just done tomorrow
do you have the hard drives in the safe
place though hey yeah you got to get it
safe gotta keep them safe
you can't let this [__] happen again
was that um
disheartening to have your music leaked
and [__] hurt me how many songs was it
it was like 200
200 songs because they leak do you
decide to not drop them at all yeah I
mean like [__] that [__] they ain't
already heard it so [__] I know it's
like me for that [__] you know what you
got to do and all them song they lead
the [__] oh them [__] won't even
know them that's probably gonna piss you
off even more like this [__] they were
old and that was just one producer
[Music]
you should drop them as like you know
not you know Nas the rapper now so
obviously yeah he has the lost tape
Series so he'll put out like a bunch of
unreleased [__]
football one of his best albums ever is
the first Lost Tapes but it was like a
compilation of songs that never came out
or leaked no over like a 10-year period
or something like that he made good mine
off that [__] it's a lot though I mean
bro you could put out a 200 song mixtape
but just Gucci so I think Gucci's last
album has like a a [__] 78 songs on
it
did you see that no yeah the new Gucci
album has like I think it's like 80
songs I can't listen to no [__] with
that many songs I can't listen to 80
something I don't know the last time
I've listened to 80 songs like
a month is that a lot that what I'm
saying I don't see how the hell they're
gonna how the hell y'all gonna listen to
him or something yeah yeah you listen to
podcasts pug yeah like or interviews or
like you know it depends
what do you like to listen to people
talk about anime nine depends on where
going on in the world
or where's somebody saying or some [__]
I might want to go see they see what
they said in the podcast myself
so I can feel like how I pulled the feel
about the situation type [__] you
somebody like someone said something
about you nah just in general we'll be
speaking about some [__]
now you might see somebody to bash
somebody on Instagram they say oh he
said that I go see what he said yeah
cause you can't just trust the headline
yeah yeah no you can't never turn no
[__] like that that's some real [__]
[__] probably got now we're speaking
some real [__] [__] you never uh said
what your favorite anime ever was man
I thought we were gonna run around that
[__] that [__] up
my favorite anime set
I mean I feel like that was everybody
favorite anime dragon ball yeah like as
a kid
woman yeah Dragon Ball was the one yeah
yeah as a kid yeah yeah but now my
favorite anime probably like
um
how'd you I fought with one punch man
that [__] oh what is the premise
my son watches that what's it about
there's no little is there a little I'm
trying to I'm trying to think
it's about getting punched once
let me Google it
one bunch
he basically like it like
I don't know because it's time for his
head on just straight just punch like
one punch out tight [__] you know what
I'm saying but
like majority of all the people he
really get into it with
is it called one punch man yeah one
punishment
oh I see is like a ball dude yeah he
bald head
this fool looks like [__]
this fool looks like goddamn he ain't
got no superpowers either
so we just oh look at him when he hit
him like he's like a nerdy dude yeah
yeah
so why so is he he
he's trying to say I don't know how the
[__] he trying to sell to be be got down
that goddamn so he's a super so it's
about a superhero who's normal
yeah like you're a human basically yeah
you ever watch The Boondocks The
Boondocks yeah yeah
Boondocks is amazing Boondock gonna
always be that [__]
two seasons of The Boondocks are good
the last season was a little because the
main Rider quit yeah man I I like what's
your favorite character
I mean I love
I love Riley
right I mean Gramps is funny
I like what's the racist black dude who
hates yeah I know who I like wait no
Uncle Ruckus I said Clayton Bixby that's
Dave spell scary Uncle Ruckus yeah Uncle
Ricky that probably is the finest
[__] on that [__] Bro now [__]
stupid as hell he said anything he don't
give a damn hold on bro Uncle Ruckus
I have so my best friend's brother works
on
you got to hear this drop
if I have it
this is the actual actor is this it hold
on hey America this is Uncle Ruckus no
relation I don't even know he dressed
and sound like a donkey he listening to
the Great
oh Lord he smelled like Financial polish
and lemon zest God bless his white skin
camp
[Laughter]
yes out for the hill man bro I mean
he'll [__] [__] but he funny what was
like because the guy who voices a few of
the characters include Uncle Ruckus yeah
he did a drop he was doing radio drops
and [__] so I was like bro I need a
Uncle Ruckus drop
yeah man that [__] funny hell man you
seen the one when he was a little kid
yes I've seen them all that [__] was so
goddamn funny boy yeah I like uh I like
the uh the the episode where the look
The the [__] lawyer dude
his wife gets snatched by Usher
do you remember the episodes Usher
snatches this dude's [__] and then he
goes and hires a pimp named slickback to
try to get his girl back
is [__] hilarious by the way oh oh
the pimp yeah
I know the little pimp with the pink
with the little yeah yeah I know that
cat we didn't care but yeah yeah the
parent will finally had to this oh so
good man so good